yeah yeah so this is my sister Melissa
[Music]
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Samuel Leeds
I'm a property investor and I like to
help other people become property
investors every single week I bring
someone onto my youtube channel that
I've helped become a property investor
or a property entrepreneur and this week
I'm ridiculously excited this is one of
the specialists guests we've ever had on
winners Wednesday that is Melissa and
the check in younger who is my sister so
welcome to the show hi so you got
starting property recently ish yes I
would say officially about a year ago as
I had been really serious about it I
attended the crash course in February of
2019
and I loved it and then I kind of came
away from it didn't really do much and
then went again I think it must have
been in like the June and then that's
when I officially side actually like
smashing it and you know trying to do
deals and stuff but I didn't actually
find a deal until later on okay now we
have to address the elephant because
people might be thinking Samuel said his
sister we don't look that similar so
you're Amanda's sister being in African
culture we don't say in-laws yeah we're
siblings yeah you've had family and I
got quite a lot of hate on Facebook
because it was stated that you paid full
price for some advanced training and
people were like I can't believe you
charged your little sister cuz you're
how old - yeah yeah company be charged
your little sister full price for
training how horrible what do you have
to say about that honestly what's the
big deal like the thing is I feel like
people think that just because my family
I might get a free pass or whatever but
in life you don't get free passes and I
feel like you never said to me you need
to pay it you just said do you want to
go on the training and of course like I
thought well yeah it's worth the money
that it's worth and I don't want to rip
you off you know y'all spending time and
stuff putting this all together and so
your team and everything like I never
even thought about going for free are
asking to go for free because it's just
it's not really me so I thought well
yeah I'm gonna pay it and I did and I
loved it
did you make your investment back yeah I
made it back and then I made it back
again that's really cool so yeah and I
think as well we've trained in I know
your your family but I believe when you
don't pay you don't pay attention
yeah for sure I feel like because I paid
and I when I was literally just like
everyone else like I paid attention like
everyone else I mingled with everyone
else and no one obviously knew really
that we were late or anything and it it
just I was just there like everyone else
and that's to learn to meet people to
like network and I loved it I feel like
if I went for free I might have like
switched off a bit you know and like
being like oh you know I can just come
again next time if I missed this bit but
it wasn't like that I was there and I
was fully immersed in it and it was
amazing I wish we could do it all again
yeah well you can and you know what's
funny though I've had some people in my
family not a side of the family but
different family members they have like
said to me awesome you know I want to
meet and talk about property or I want
to pick your brains and I've been hard
to be fair they are sort of family you
know cousin or whatever and we've met
and I've spent time and I've gone over
everything and then they've done
absolutely nothing well yeah that's the
thing I feel like when you pay the money
you feel like oh well I've paid it's not
even about getting the money back I feel
it for me it wasn't that it was just
well I might as well now put into use
what I've learned I just don't want it
to be dead knowledge that's my brain and
then I'll lose motivation you know to do
it but I feel like at the DfE you really
get stuck into finding deals put them
together ring and agents and stuff and
you do get that buzz and that buzz
continues and it goes on with you when
you go home and you're like ah really
want to find deals and that's exactly
what happened to me so I loved it so oh
I've been married 2 - 6 years and I've
been running crash courses for four
years and you came to the first crash
course just last year so like what
happened how did you first hear about
the training what did you think when you
first found out that I was a property
tycoon and I ran training but how did
the whole thing come about for you so
you ran crash classes and I knew about
them because dad went to a few of them
as well and I don't know at that point I
just never really thought about
property being something for me like
we'd had chats about budgeting and stuff
like that and you were like I'll do this
jar system it really works and surfing
at the time I was just like yeah but in
terms of property I feel like I never
really saw myself going into it it was
only until later on that I thought
actually this sounds really good and
that's why I went to the crash course
because I thought you know what even
though I've got a full-time job and I'm
a university student I feel like I can
still fit that in to my Overson busy
schedule which is very busy sometimes so
I just felt like I needed to submerge
myself into it and then when I found out
that obviously amanda was dating this
guy obviously we'd met at the wedding so
we met at the wedding that you and
Amanda mad at you know at the same time
so I kind of knew you but I didn't know
about your property stuff and neither
did she
and then it kind of just happened like
you kind of told her something and then
she told me and I was like wow I don't
really understand it I was still quite
young I was just that uh cool rushed off
of it but yeah I just I just never
really thought about I feel like I was
probably really focused on purely doing
like I think at that time would have
been my a-levels and then getting a job
and stuff like that and you like
coaching me through that and stuff as
well so I remember you saying actually
we had this conversation when I was
applying for jobs because it was our
first ever job that I was applying for
and you were like go for the know like
if you apply and they say no that's fine
move on to the next one just keep on
going and keep on going and that kind of
mentality really helped me at that time
and I feel like I've really grown from
that since then and you do really well
on your career solid as well I mean for
22 what are you studying at unit
quantity surveying okay and you're also
a quantity surveyor yeah yeah and how's
that how's that going at work because I
know you do really enjoy your job as
well yeah I do so I basically doing a
part-time degree which is five years and
I'm working full-time alongside that so
the two combined honestly golddust I
feel like I've learned so much on the
job and my day-to-day kind of role and
stuff really opens that my eyes to the
world of construction and
kind of just everything really and then
uni as well it just it helps to like
give an academic aspect on everything
and you know it's just good I feel like
together combined I've just really
learned a lot and they're now bringing
property is like a third element of that
it all honestly just feels like it was
all meant to be yeah and you must be
really busy though because you're
working full-time in quant in
construction yeah
you're studying at University now you're
doing property and you've done four
deals now yeah which you've packaged and
you've sold on which we'll get to and
we'll talk about but I think it's great
I really admire your work ethic and I
know you love your uni work you love
your job talk to me about the four deals
that you've done and how that happened
so the DfE was I think it was November I
then went on holiday skiing in December
I didn't do any deals between that time
and going skiing and then on my first
day of skiing I broke my leg and I was
obviously very very upset so I came back
from the holiday and I wasn't working
because I was on really heavy medication
and stuff and I was just there was a lot
of things going through her mind I just
thought oh my gosh like if this had been
much worse and I could potentially you
know like maybe not walk or something
like that like what would my bank
balance say would that be able to
sustain me and like do I have like a
passive income and I just thought no I
do and what like god forbid if I was to
ever lose my job or anything like that I
just I'd want to be in a position where
I feel comfortable and I feel like I can
be independent so I'm quite an
independent person and I think just
losing my leg and being really down in
the dumps like I delete to use to cry
like all the time because if the pain
everything I just it really gave me a
kick and I was just like you know what I
need to just start being really
productive with my dead time because
it's it needs to happen so that's kind
of what gave me the drive to find my
deals and in the month of January
I found basically four deals which made
me quite a bit of money so that and I
think I realized at the point where I
was getting better and I was obviously
working again
my actual job full-time I thought well I
need to be able to balance them all
because I feel like I can't do one thing
really strongly and then neglect other
things so I just had to really find the
balance between them all and time manage
everything really well and I feel like I
found that balance now but you honestly
like it's it is hard at times but I just
have realized that property can be
almost like my productive pastime which
just earns me a lot of money instead of
just going through Instagram which I
still do obviously yeah that's so cool
so I mean I remember when I directed own
and it was just like oh my goodness
because you were about you just finished
the deal finding extravaganza you'd go
all of the knowledge and you're like
yeah I'm gonna go skiing and then I'm
gonna come back and then I'm gonna start
doing deals and then you broke your leg
and it was like and you phoned being
Amanda I think while you're in hospital
like the same day you broke your leg and
it was really bad so thank God that
you're walking again now okay and the
fact that you were able to just do deals
so what was you what was your first deal
how did you because you you from my
recollection you didn't have a company
you didn't have you package some sort
deals but you weren't compliant you
didn't have money sitting around to
invest so you got to use pretty creative
strategies which was Co deal sourcing
yeah so what is code deal sourcing so
Kerr deal sourcing is when you find deal
you view it you stack up the numbers and
then you pass on that deal to a main
deal saucer that main deal saucer then
passes that deal on to an investor if
they're interested the investor will buy
it and then you'll get a cut of that fee
that they pay for that deal and that
worked well for you because you didn't
necessarily have time to be meeting up
with investors you didn't want to
necessarily set up a whole business you
just wanted to do focus on the property
bit and make some money without having
to do loads and loads of extra work yeah
and I couldn't really cuz I was you know
I couldn't walk so I couldn't really go
out and meet people and stuff like that
so what I did was I basically heard
about view bur from your crash course
and then I think you mentioned at the
DfE and I thought well I can't go out
and do viewing so I'm just gonna have to
get someone to basically do the viewings
for me so found a really good property
used a really good return on investment
calculation sheet and put the numbers in
there the deal stacked and it was
actually below market value single that
so single let's usually aren't really
that popular anymore but if they're
below market value I feel like investors
really jumped for them so this one was
like 20% below market value it was it
was quite good so I then sold that deal
sorry I then booked a viewing for that
deal passed on to the view BRR agent and
then they went to view it and they came
back with the report videos everything
and then I basically just put an offer
in got to accept it and then passed on
to the main deal sauce how did it feel
when the offer was accepted I was over
the moon I was so happy I mean it was my
first offer to be accepted and I
honestly like I couldn't contain myself
over oh my god like I was in bad mouse
with a broken leg like brace on crutches
by the side like Hiram s like honestly
it just felt so good and it just gave me
a drive to find more and find more and
then I found three others and they
literally all like yeah it just happened
in the space of like a few cheese a lot
while you were in that broken state
working from home yeah
which just shows what's possible even
from home yeah give me some tips on how
to negotiate offers because you you
first offer that you put forward and it
wasn't accepted and you said to me I'm
working on it working on it we couldn't
quite make it stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah
I do and then you're the lease option
agreement what was and you were like the
vendors an idiot I've offered them a
brilliant to do that they don't need the
money now what is that I never actually
I've changed my mind
so you had a few knows what tips on
lessons would you learn about getting a
good deal of negotiating so honestly you
mentioned the lease option and that was
my first I had many nerves prior to that
but that was my first know that really
deciding it hit me in the gut
kind of thing I literally drove all the
room and I had this idea of my head of
pers miss Lee's option to this couple
and I just knew it was perfect for them
like I felt it was perfect for them I
was driving
was really hot oh my gosh like
rehearsing in my head go up there had a
nice cup of tea with them built some
rapport sat down went through everything
I offered them a lease option I offered
to buy the house below market value and
then a lease option thereafter and they
said no basically and I remember driving
away being like oh ok like man then six
weeks later they rang me while the agent
rang me being like hi you know the offer
they put forward like they're actually
interested and I was oh my gosh
fantastic and then it didn't go through
but still I was like you know what that
just shows ups and downs and I feel like
through that I learned that even when
you're negotiating always always be nice
just be a good person because I feel
like if I was an idiot when they said no
the first time and I was like oh well
guys you don't know what's good for you
what the hell kind of thing they'd have
been like all right bye like we don't
need your kind of thing but I was see
for understanding I was just like you
know what guys it's completely fine like
it's not for everyone you know let me
know if you need anything in the future
I'll be always you know I'll be there to
listen and that's lit - what they did
they call me back and they were like we
need you know if he's still interested
let's do it
didn't go ahead because they decide not
to sell but I just feel like the
underpinning thing of everything should
just be have a good heart and have good
intentions and everything will just be
fine I mean oh so true and I think the
number side of it which you've got
really good at the whole number side of
it is one thing and then the other side
is just being a good person and trying
to help people you just know that you
said the least obviously won't fit
really well how do you work out
I mean firstly what is a lease option
agreement in summary and how do you work
out if a lease option agreement is good
for someone so in your case how did you
know that at least option agreement
would be a good offer right so a lease
option agreement is when you offer
someone to buy their house later but in
the meantime rent their property off of
them saw asset figure and then that
basically like covers their mortgage and
then you can then rent out that property
to someone else and then basically
you're getting the rent from someone
paying them the figure to pay off their
mortgage and then in X amount of years
you can then buy that property for them
for a pre agreed price well you've got
the option to not the obligation so if
it gets to that
time in the future and you feel like you
don't really fancy in it you don't have
to go ahead but that's basically what it
is and I knew that I felt like this
property was a perfect Lease Option
opportunity just because they'd
basically bought it in 2009 when the
market was kind of in a rocky place and
they were now trying to sell it for a
lot less than what they paid for it and
it just meant that they were a negative
equity and I could tell all this from
Rightmove and you know just doing a
little bit of research on the property
so I did my due diligence due diligence
beforehand and I I knew this and I knew
going in there all the questions to kind
of ask them to get them to tell me
because I wanted them to obviously open
up and stuff and they did so that's kind
of how I knew that the house was a
perfect lease option agreement and then
you made your offer and you even video
recorded yourself and you sent it to me
and you were brilliant
you offered it beautifully Wow you had
really good relationship with them but
it just didn't sit right with with them
yeah exactly and the reason why I record
today obviously I had that permission to
do so I did it because I wanted to see
how I acted in the situation I wanted to
be able to kind of look back on it and
think oh actually I should have done
this I should have done that and even
literally on like like going home I knew
I thought oh my gosh
I should have said this I should have
you know done this and I was having
flashbacks of your crash course and you
being like make sure I do this make sure
you do that exhaust the options and I
just knew that I hadn't done certain
bits correctly but I just had something
to look back on so that the next time I
did it I was much better
yeah that's great so tell me about the
first deal that you negotiated to get
below market value 20% below market
value and give me the best piece of
advice you can for somebody right now in
these times it's getting a bargain
property oh I would say number one make
sure that whatever they're selling
selling it for is actually in line with
what you believe is correct because what
could happen is they could be putting it
on the market for much more than it's
worth you knock it down
think you've got a fantastic deal when
actually yeah yeah you can just be like
you know proper duped so I would say do
you research first how do you do that
research
oh well wouldn't you like to know so I
use a website called Mouse Price and I
also use Rightmove to look at sold
nearby comparables and I basically just
run some figures put them in a
calculator and then it just kind of
works out for me I kind of just get a
good feeling as to how that property
lines up with the market and once I feel
like I've got a really good idea on that
and that I then think about putting in
an offer so that's kind of the bit where
I get a bit nervous sometimes and I are
probably much better at it now but
initially I thought oh my gosh they're
gonna think I'm really silly you're
putting forward a very low offer you
made yeah did you have any agents
getting upset with you I had a few that
were like well you'll need to view the
property first yeah yeah because do you
do the yeah yeah so it's a soft test
right you're on the phone you know I
love this property you know so good
great location by ah blah like how long
has it been on the market for even
though you can see all that stuff I
might move you just asked to build a
rapport right and then you're like okay
so so you said it's been on the property
since February have they had many
viewings and they're like oh no you know
Korona and you're like ah yeah that's
fine well do you think they'd be willing
to maybe kind of budge on the asking
price a little bit would they maybe you
know consider X amount and then they'll
say well I'm afraid you'll just have to
view the property first you know we
can't you know it's a really good
property you just paint in the walls
he's just painted the carpet you know it
he feels like that is the best price for
it and you kind of feel them getting a
bit and you think all right no worries
that's fine I'll book a viewing when can
we do it for and you just move on and
you go and view the house you put
forward your offer and like you say your
first offer should never be what you
want you should be almost embarrassed
about it because if they accept your
first offer it means you've done
something wrong like yeah it's so I've
just used that mentality base yeah but
then I guess if they if they say
absolutely no way they'd accept that
offer yeah then you might think okay
well I won't bother you yeah but if
fella okay well there could be
interested come on over look round it's
like the pre-offer yeah and then the
actual offer were you nervous when you
put forward the offer I would say yeah I
was like oh my gosh I mean most of these
things are done on email because
obviously speaking to the agent and you
know they'll pass it on to the vendor so
most times I'm not speaking to the
vendor directly so it feels a little bit
less like nerve-wracking but even still
you kind of think and then there were
times where the agent would come back
really quickly and be like they've said
this and I'm like oh no like what do I
do because obviously I'm not the one
selling the deal so I need to make sure
that whatever I say to the agent is
actually correct because yeah I'm not
the one selling the deal at the end of
the day so how do you find someone who
will sell the deal for you good question
so I just so happen to know really good
person and they say haven't you a
boyfriend so James Armstrong basically
is a really really fantastic deal Saucer
and he started deal sourcing about the
same time that we met pretty much so
we've kind of like I've seen him
progress in that and it's just been
really great so I know that he can sell
deals and I feel like whoever you're
gonna use make sure that they can sell
deals because if you pass on to deal
sorcerer who can't sell deals or
whatever you'll never get any cut of
that fee because if you will never come
so I just feel like you know it just so
happen that I know James and you know it
just works out really well but he
doesn't give me any special treatment or
anything like that I have to do all my
due diligence he won't do it for me I
have to go out and view the properties I
have to make sure the deal stack and
then all I do then is pass it to him and
say right here's a you know the sheet
here are the figures here the
comparables please try and pass it on to
an investor and how would you let's say
James Armstrong said I don't want to do
that anymore I know I am without a
shadow of a doubt no question that you'd
be able to find somebody else that would
sell the deal how would you go about
finding someone else without dating them
I would honestly I made such good
contacts at the DfE so I feel like those
people that I met
I could literally just link up with them
and be like guys like do anyone know who
you know do you know anyone who sells
deals or is a deal sorcerer and they'll
literally be able just to help me out
and I feel like having connections
within the industry is really great but
not even that I could literally just ask
you probably and I'll be like James yeah
that's right yeah what would you say the
biggest lessons over the last six months
are how long has been have been on your
property journey what are the biggest
key points I'd say number one don't
create excuses for yourself I think a
lot of people create the excuse for
themselves to say I don't have enough
time and stuff like that and obviously
we've just been through a period where
everyone has has a lot more time than
they thought they would ever have and I
think if you didn't do productive things
in the past however many months it's
been what three maybe
and then obviously time isn't your
problem its discipline and I just think
when you create excuses for yourself
the only person is going to suffer is
you so no excuses is number one number
two is time management because I think
even if you don't have a lot of time you
can still get things done like I'm a uni
student I've got assignments to do I
need to go to uni I need to pass I need
to do well I've also got a job and I
just think finding time to do things
whether it's on an evening or during
like the weekends I like in-between
viewings even is just it's just valuable
you need to just make time for things
and I'd say number three is just make
sure that whatever you do you do it with
good intentions and you do it correctly
because if you kind of speak to an agent
badly or you have like a bad vibe or you
just you very rude people I think it can
really come back to you and I've spoken
to a lot of the same age and it's over
the past few months and I'll ring them
up and they won't recognise me
because until they you know ask my
details and I'm booking a viewing but I
know them and I know that if I was
blacklisted because I had like hung up
the phone on them or what was just rude
which was obviously out of my character
anyway but if I was that person and then
I'd completely blacklist myself from a
patch and I think having a good patch is
really valuable and you need to have
good links so that's kind of two-in-one
be nice have good links build
relationships with people and yeah
that's really really good and I think
it's a really small world the property
world in terms of steel sources even
investors estate agents and you write
when you start building a good
reputation packaging and selling good
deals only being nice to people and time
management such an important one you've
juggled your time so well even on the
deal finding extravaganza if I remember
you said to me Samuel I definitely want
to do it I'm all up for it but it
clashes with my exam my uni exam and we
had a conversation about it
and talk to me about that and what
happened oh man so honestly that day
I was so scared so basically I booked
off annually for the three days that the
deal extravaganza kind of rang a run
across and I thought well that's fine
but I've got an exam on the Thursday now
this is gonna be tricky cuz my exam is
and leaves and the deal fund
extravaganza is in Birmingham or like
wherever wherever it was and I was like
okay so I can either go for my exam and
then go to the DfE afterwards then that
means I miss an entire morning which
you've said is the best day come on
[Applause]
every second is the best yeah yeah yeah
literally Sal's our man so I had to do
was wake up at the crack of dawn I I
think I went to the DfE for a couple of
hours in the morning drove to Leeds and
then did my exam I was like so nervous
like flustered didn't even have time to
like do much eat or anything like that
did my exam went straight back into my
car back down to Birmingham
to finish off the DfE day and it was
honestly like it was just one of those
days where I thought to myself I could
have so easily been like I'm not gonna
go to the DfE I talks I'm paying X
amount for it and I don't want to miss a
day so I'm just not gonna go but that
wouldn't have helped me at all and
actually even though I did miss a little
bit I still learn so so much and I just
feel like that day I was like at the end
of the day I was like oh yeah like I'm
gonna bust it like I'm gonna be alright
like you just have to get on with it
so many people that would have either
not done the exam and been like you know
F school yeah she's okay that would
probably what I would have done but then
other people would have would have said
I'm not going to go to the deal fine
extravaganza I'm not going to learn
about property because I got an exam
yeah some people would have not done
either and when it just cracked under
the pressure and stayed in bed but you
went out and did both yeah you broke
your leg and you worse then you continue
to be successful you do you're being a
property entrepreneur you're not waiting
to finish uni you're not waiting you're
doing it alongside building your career
as a quantity surveyor so I know I think
that's really admirable you're 22 years
old
what can the next few years look like I
feel like I really want to progress in
my career as a quantity surveyor and
just smash that keep on smashing that
and just like really kind of grow in the
company I've been there for three years
now so I feel like I lived in there for
seven years in five years
sorry eight years and five years quick
maths and honest yeah I just I just
really want to do well in that but
equally I want to really get more of a
passive income as well through property
and at the minute it is my pastime but I
do want to try and like you know just
really be more consistent on that get
more deals in still be a car deal sauce
I'm not really interested in the minute
of being a main deal sorcerer but yeah
Co deal sauce deals maybe do bigger
deals as well and just find them and
just keep it going
another thing as well which I really
admire about the way you're doing it
you've not even set up per se like I've
been company if you're just doing it in
your past
when most people would be watching box
sets you're on Rightmove and talking to
agents talking to motivated sellers when
most people will be out viewing shops
and going and looking at clothes I know
you do that too yeah a lot far too often
yeah but you'll be doing that and yeah
your will view in houses you know you're
really somebody that doesn't say which
one you always just say both to both to
life both business both to success so
that's really exciting what would you
say to somebody being as unbiased as
possible because I know we're family
that was considering doing the property
investors crash course or I'll just get
this out there and if you knew this the
deal find the extravaganza that you went
to we've put that on the samuel 365 is
on there as well it's on there as well
fantastic
I didn't know that but I knew that you
were running the 365 and that it was at
the crash class but online that's
fantastic but I don't know how long it's
gonna be on there right now as we speak
I think it's on there by donor how much
longer but anyway someone that's
thinking of doing Samuel 365 the crash
course further development training
whether that be with me or whether that
be of somebody else but what would you
say to someone that was thinking of
investing their time investing their
money to educate yourself on property
investment do it just do it honestly
best investment I've ever made because I
feel like investing in your own
education is just something that will
never ever be like you know better well
spent
I think the DfE honestly taught me so so
much and samuel 365 isn't unlike one
pound
it's one pound for seven days then not
if I've pam-pam yeah so how much did you
invest for the deal fine extravaganza oh
yeah about two and a half yeah Tina yeah
yeah yeah
yeah that's not much so if you compare
that there to a pound I made it back and
then I made it back again yeah literally
so no no way because I feel like you
will make it back tenfold if you put the
effort in obviously you're not gonna pay
for courses and stuff whether it's yours
or anyone elses and just miraculously be
able to find deals in your sleep like
you know without doing anything you need
to put in the work and I feel like once
you've paid the money you you feel it
at the beginning and you're like oh man
I paid that was you know that was for me
the most I've ever spent
I mean besides you know like cars and
stuff but like that's the most I've ever
spent upfront and I think just doing
that it was like wow this is this is a
big deal so honestly training so so
valuable and I've had a few people you
know messaging me being like wow you're
22 I really you know they'll say oh I'm
18 I want to get into property and I'm
like check out this that this like you
know training
Samuel 365 and I'll tell them my story
about going to the crash courses and how
they were free and how I loved it and
how they can now get the same knowledge
and then some for a pound for seven days
and then you know a certain amount
afterwards like it's fantastic so so
good I can't believe you doing it to
affair oh thank you thank you
you're amazing how people connect with
you if they want to connect with you
Instagram
you're amazing on Instagram you don't go
often but when you do it's always an
amazing picture yeah thank you
yes so basically I've got an Instagram
platform and then I like basically have
an Instagram channel as well on that
saying what she means to come handle
Mele Antico underscarf
Mele MPL ly yeah and the word yeah Co Co
underscarf Mele & Co underscore yeah
follow Mele anko underscore and
Instagram you also have a website yeah I
do
how much you how much do you pay to get
that website up and run or did you do it
yourself a free I did it myself a free
boom there we go you know what
everything you've done your code your
sort of the way you've started the
business yeah apart from the education
side because you know that's the most
important all the other stuff most
people would spend two and a half grand
on business cards website yes that the
other you didn't have to do that because
you did it for free but you invested
first in yourself what's the name of
your website Mele anchor calm
Mele encode calm simple awesome and also
on my Instagram channel I basically
perfect video Zahn little how to's yeah
there are those yeah so they're like
property how to's or I just talk about
my experience and stuff so if you want
to like see anything about that and
you've also like doesn't really cool it
or giveaways on your website like ROI
spreadsheet yeah
yeah I've got some really good golden
nuggets on that oh yeah yeah if you want
to work out your return on investment
really quickly just go my website
download the sheet you know you'll be
great so go down to Mellie and
koat-dot-com
yeah and follow Mellie and Co underscore
on Instagram folks hope you enjoyed the
interview I think you'll agree she's
amazing check them out you wanted to be
part of the samuel 365 go to Samuel
365.com get all the same training that
Melissa had also I hope to see you at
the property investors crash course on
real soon thanks for watching subscribe
smash the like button drop a comment
below and I'll see you next time